Hey youtubers, it’s Charlie and the Oscars
are here.
I’ll be doing a proper Oscars Winner video
later tonight, but before that I wanted to
do a video for all the fandoms and fandom
actors that we wish would win an Oscar.
Because the Oscars are the most professionally
respected awards I’m bending rules and including
things like Doctor Who and television shows
based on certain criteria.
Oscars are for motion pictures only and you
could argue that the People’s Choice Awards
is kind of like the Fandom Oscars.
But the real Oscars are voted on by a group
of Hollywood peers.
Mostly old men.
So let’s just have some fun with this and
do best picture, best actor, best actress
and best supporting actor and actress.
The really funny thing about all this is that
sometimes actors that win real life Oscars
actually have starred in some of your favorite
fandoms in the past.
It’s just that some people or directors
or writers get there start on a science fiction
or genre show and then later in life go on
to become hugely successful.
But part of the reason I wanted to do this
is that most of the time the people that Vote
on the real life Oscars really hate Science
Fiction and genre.
For instance Christopher Nolan has only ever
been nominated for an Oscar for his Memento
screenplay and for Inception.
He didn’t win either.
Inception lost to King’s Speech, which is
exactly the kind of movie you call Oscar-Bait.
So let’s talk about our favorite Fandoms
we think deserve Oscars.
Remember for this two-part episodes count
as a movie.
Let’s start with Best Supporting Actress
- We have to start with Michelle Fairly for
The Red Wedding.
She’s amazing as Catelyn Stark in general
and since the show is so serialized I’ll
include her.
Then there’s Amanda Abbington in His Last
Vow as Mary Morstan, now Mary Morstan Watson.
They have to compete with Evangeline Lily,
one of the few females in Desolation of Smaug
this year, but an amazing performance nonetheless.
Feel free to make any additions for supporting
actresses in your favorite fandom in the comments.
Next is best supporting actor.
We have to include Lars Mikkelsen as Charles
Augustus Magnussen.
Such a great villain.
And every bit as scary as his brother Mads
Mikkelsen in Hannibal.
Then there’s both David Tennant and John
Hurt in the Doctor Who 50th Anniversary.
Then there’s Philip Seymour Hoffman in Catching
Fire, Idris Elba in Pacific Rim and I’d
like to nominate all of the dwarves from Desolation
of Smaug as one collective group.
They could just share one Oscar statue if
they won.
Technically I consider Richard Armitage to
be one of the main star’s so I’ll nominate
him when I get to Best Actor.
Technically we also need to include Benedict
Cumberbatch.
I consider Smawg to be a supporting character
even though he’s so big.
Now it’s time for Best Actress though.
These are the leads from each movie or fandom.
Starting off with the easy one.
Jennifer Lawrence in Catching Fire.
She’ll get attention at the actual Oscars
for American Hustle, but it’s probably her
Hunger Games stuff that most of us know her
from.
The other easy ones being Sandra Bullock in
Gravity.
And Scarlett Johansson in Her.
Great science fiction if you haven’t seen
them yet.
Some of the few science fiction movies that
are actually getting legit recognition this
awards season.
There’s actually a lot of actresses on my
list in genre movies for this so I’ll try
to cut it down to the best.
Jessica Chastain in Guillermo Del Toro’s
Mama.
It’s a horror movie.
Rinko Kikuchi in Pacific Rim, one of the most
badass female characters all year.
Both Kristin Bell and Idina Menzel in Frozen.
They should all win for Let It Snow too.
And I can’t leave off Amy Acker in Joss
Whedon’s Much Ado About Nothing.
On to best Actor.
Starting off with Benedict Cumberbatch and
Martin Freeman for the entirety of Sherlock
Series 3, Matt Smith in the 50th Anniversary
Special, Tony Leung in Won Kar-Wai’s Grandmaster
as Ip Man, so awesome.
Alexis Denisof also in Much Ado About Nothing.
I kind of want to include Tom Hiddleston for
Only Lovers Left Alive, but they moved the
release date so technically it’s a 2014
movie.
And lastly Peter Dinklage, in everything.
But mostly Game of Thrones this season.
So here’s my best picture pics.
I tried to narrow it down to the best of the
best.
There were a lot of awesome things, and some
of them are actually getting recognized at
the real life Oscars.
But first there’s Spike Jonze’s Her, it
was actually my favorite theatrical film next
to Miyazaki’s The Wind Rises.
Those are two movies you have to see.
Wind Rises is actually nominated for best
Foreign Language film, which I hope it wins.
But I think it should be included for Best
Picture overall.
Then there’s Desolation of Smaug, it was
one of the only movies in addition to The
Wind Rises that I paid to see more than once
in a movie theater.
Then Gravity from Alfonso Cuaron, I love all
of his movies, but Gravity is amazing.
And that’s my list, let me know what your
favorite sci fi or genre movie was this year
and whether or not you think it deserves an
Oscar.
Like I said, I’ll be doing a real Oscar
Winner’s video tonight.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll also be posting a new Walking Dead
Episode.
Right now click here for that Oscar Winners
Video.
I’ll add the annotation tonight when I post
it.
And Click here to catch up on Walking Dead
before tonight’s episode.
Thanks for watching, see you tonight.
High Fives!